the when you what you mentioned about
bravery this how you were talking with
sam harris about it where bravery is
only present if you are scared of
something because if you're not scared
of it you're not being brave to overcome
anything or to go you know to do any
kind of activity that's you know that
you're scared of so the very although I
don't know if I necessarily agree with
that because there's guys that are you
know he says you never seen anyone
that's not not afraid I think some
pretty cool I mean it's almost the word
uses are crazy guys that are just so
brave and you look at him and they you
big eagle this guy's gonna sky I had
guys with me you know in my task unit
and some of those guys were so brave
that I didn't think they were gonna make
it home and is it because they were like
it's like they they weren't scared to
die at all like you didn't yeah and and
you see the almost a lack of
self-preservation right you know not not
stupid not not suicidal
but like oh this guy doesn't think he
can be killed you know we were talking
about that on the last podcast I forget
the name of the major that was on the
beach landing at taro I think and he's
up and he's like hey look they can't hit
me come on yeah I've seen guys do that
yeah so as far as actual bravery goes
though so would you consider that um
like let's say k2 guys are going to go
go do some let's say an MMA fight right
and one guys just really scared of
competing in front of people it's his
first flight of them like that then you
have this other guy who's not who just
feels different same exact situation but
you have fired up he's not scared at all
and they both go into it did they both
exercise the same bravery yeah I don't
know you know yeah and I don't know if
it matters yeah for one thing I can tell
you the guy that's acting like he's not
scared
probably the one that's more scared yes
whenever they flex right and I actually
see that combat through guys that are
overly like bravado are probably more
scared and and again there's nothing
wrong with that I'm not holding it
against them but you know I've seen guys
sitting in briefs to go out on
operations that you can tell are
petrified yeah usually it's a guy that's
not used to it maybe maybe someone
that's visiting in an area of operations
and shows up and so we're going to take
you on an operation and you get to see
them they're very scared because they're
not used to it all the guys from my task
unit you know they might be scared but
they're confident they know what they're
doing right there they've put that fear
aside over and over again so it's not
that big of a deal but you see a guy
dealing with that fear for the first
time yeah and especially stands out
because you've got a bunch of confident
guys that that know that understand that
understand the risks so you can see
their faces then you see like that guys
come in from another area and it's going
to go out an operation and and they're
they're tapping their toes during the
brief and they're looking around yeah
and they got overcome that fear and if
they stay there for a few weeks they'll
they'll get used to it too yeah so it
could kind of be looked at as just just
the act itself whatever act if it's
understood and being yeah Sam Harris's
point was that it doesn't matter if
there's a machine-gun nest and you're
horrified to go charge it and I'm not
and we both go charge it it you just had
to pretend that you weren't scared it
doesn't matter you were still being
brave right right and and I didn't have
to pretend but I'm being brave so it
doesn't matter what under pretending or
not you're brave if you go right and or
maybe just to overcome or do something
that's understood generally as being
scary it's not guarantee just Garak you
you're still being different brave you
are but yeah I say and I guess in a real
black-and-white terms it's like if
you're not scared of this activity
you're doing and you do it you're not
scared of it then you're not being brave
is not just in generally speaking like
no to your example skydivers yeah
skydivers were five
jeomsun up right they're not scared
anymore yeah I mean I know even when I
had done like you know 50 jumps you're
not really scared anymore
right you're just doing it and guys it
has thousands jumping on scare at all
that's what they do
right so they're not being brave they're
just doing their job they're just doing
their thing yeah so what if some guys
jumping out for the first time and he's
scared and he overcomes that fear and
jumps out he is being brave yeah all
right so there yeah that's kind of a
point yeah so if I go outside and check
the mail I'm not being brave no you're
not through it but what if there's like
a tiger or something out there and I
really raised that now it's pretty brave
right Tigers going after Tigers yeah
yeah yeah you're right